well now that the floodgates are open
there is no limit to the madness you
tear down the walls which distinguish
inherently different things from each
other take fundamental human concepts
and categories and drain them of all
meaning remove the definitions of words
replace those definitions with vague
ambiguities and you end up with
unrestrained madness and this is all by
design of course that's why we now live
in a country where over this past
weekend a 29 year old father of three
took first place in a women's
skateboarding competition beating out a
13 year old girl but don't worry this
story will get even more absurd as we go
along
so just sit tight and be prepared for
that here's the report from the daily
wire says an adult biological male who
identifies as a woman edged out a 13
year old girl to take first place in a
women's skateboarding contest held in
new york saturday the feminist site
redux reported ricky trace 29
won the women's division of the border
open for a 500 prize trace bested a
field of biological females including
runner-up shiloh katori and four other
children including ten-year-old jory
lacoura
uh quote mail wins women's skateboarding
finals and money at the border open nyc
presented by dc today tweeted taylor uh
silverman a professional skateboarder
who's been critical of biological males
competing in the sport now silverman
tweeted a picture of the top six
finalists and um
if you look at the picture you can see
that
second through sixth place ranges in
ages from 28 to 10.
but what they all have in common is that
they're females
that's second through sixth place all
females they're obviously females
you wouldn't even need the names or the
context to know that they're females you
could look at a small thumbnail-sized
image of a female's face
and know immediately that she is a
female that's how clear it is
and that's why ricky trace stands out
like a sore thumb a man's sore thumb to
be precise
but i said this gets more absurd so
let's continue with the daily wire
report says
quote last year trace became the first
trans woman to attempt to qualify for
olympic women's skateboarding submitting
a virtual run for the usa national
skateboarding championships but the
biological testosterone reportedly
tested too high to allow entry as a
female under
the international olympic committee
standards so
he could not qualify as a woman for the
olympics
but he did somehow count as a woman for
this competition in new york this is the
lunacy we end up with now that we've
disregarded biology as a determining
factor for whether someone is male or
female without biology we're left with
this
ridiculous situation where an athlete
might count as a woman in one
competition but not in another
this is what happens when you erase the
objective lines of distinction and
redraw them somewhere else anywhere else
wherever you redraw them it will be
necessarily arbitrary
so arbitrary that we're expected to see
this skateboarder as some sort of
shape-shifter inhabiting a male or
female body depending on where he is and
where he's competing
but we haven't even yet traced this
rabbit hole all the way down to the
bottom
things get somehow even more ludicrous
last fall ricky trace did an interview
with the usa skateboarding youtube
channel
and there he discussed the process by
which he discovered that he was a woman
after all not but a few years ago he was
a mustachioed father of three in the
military and now he's supposedly a woman
how did this happen
well here's what he says
i didn't know that i could even be a
female if i wanted to
it was just
it was i guess it was like something i
envied i envied females when i was a kid
i would
envy their dress choice their
their like ability to be pretty and cute
and do things like that so how did that
go like how do you come out to your wife
about that and what's her reaction and
what is your guys status now
so it began it began with me
um
i had to i had to come out to myself
and that's that's kind of where all that
uh
say concluded all that guilt and regret
um
i had to i had to try to
justify it to myself like what is it
that i've i've been doing what am i
thinking who am i what am i
um
it was it was tough it was a tough
justification
yeah that's a woman there we're told you
just feel the feminine energy right
but he envies women he says and this is
remarkable only in that it was said out
loud and on camera it's entirely clear
to anyone paying attention that many
trans activists envy women and resent
women for possessing what they know they
can never have
that's why they're so often so you know
nasty and spiteful towards women at a
pride parade a few days ago a trans
person was marching around half naked
with kill the turfs written on his chest
openly advocating for the murder of
women
par for the course among trans activists
now ricky trace doesn't go that far but
he does admit to envy he wanted to be
pretty and cute he says and later in
life when seeking to explain himself to
himself and to rationalize and justify
his own past actions he used that word
justify he decides that uh well he'll
become a woman himself
except not really
because the daily mail published its own
profile of this person and they quote
him as saying this okay this is this is
from him this is what he said
i am 28 i have three kids i'm married i
did my time in the military i own a
company i've decided that i like being
pretty and cute
so everything that goes with that is
female i love female bodies i think it's
a work of art
now listen closely to this part i know i
will never be a woman because women are
miraculous they have babies and create
life and do all that awesome stuff i'll
never have that ability but i feel like
i'm a woman
i would have wished to be born one so
i'll try to fill that image as much as i
can for myself and that pretty much
involves being as cute as can be
so he says himself that he is not a
woman and will never be one he simply
likes the idea of being cute
and he wishes that he was a woman so
he's decided to play the part that's not
my diagnosis it's his own i will never
be a woman direct quote his own words
now just think about this
we're being called upon to affirm
somebody as a woman even though he does
not affirm himself as a woman
we're being asked to be more confident
in his womanhood than he is
so this goes beyond the insanity of
being forced to agree with a person's
deluded self-perception in this case
we are meant to help him shape that
self-perception
he simply as he says likes cute things
and he's envious of women
it falls to society then to take this
raw material and form it into a shape of
a self-identified woman
also note that he's on drugs as part of
his transition quote unquote that means
a doctor prescribed him hormones to be a
woman even though he doesn't actually
think he is one
again it's not just about affirming
self-perception it's about shaping that
perception and then affirming it
society has now been given the project
of creating
new trans people of course the left has
been already doing that quite eagerly
for a long time but now everyone else is
expected to participate
what other conclusion can we draw from
the fact that we are expected to refer
to somebody as a woman
and treat them as a woman even though he
only says that he wishes he was one not
that he is one
we're supposed to
grant that wish
except that it's a wish nobody can grant
because men are men and women are women
and ricky trace is today cancelled
if you want to join my exclusive fan
base or a cult as really that's what it
is we're forming a cult then all you got
to do is click the subscribe button and
ring the bell below this video to stay
up to date with all my content and if
you want even more you can watch or
listen to my show at the dailywire.com
spotify or apple podcast looking forward
to welcoming you to the sweet baby gang
you